aujourd'hui en russie la ministre des
affaires étrangères allemandes va
rencontrer pour la première fois son
homologue russe sergueï lavrov
un déplacement qui intervient en pleine
crise avec l'ukraine et hier à kiev à
l'année la barre et boch s'est engagé à
garantir la sécurité de l'ukraine tout
en prônant un dialogue sérieux avec
moscou voyez les précisions sur place de
notre correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
[Musique]
bonjour verra quels sont les enjeux de
cette rencontre aujourd'hui
bonjour mondiale et comment venir à bout
de ces différents des dossiers aussi
brûlants que la syrie la libye
l'afghanistan ou le cren c'est ce cas
avant ce à quoi vont s'employer ce
qu'est la mort et anna lena baer book au
cours de leur entretien des ministres
prévoit également discuté des
propositions russes concernant la
sécurité en europe dans son communiqué
publié la veille de la rencontre la
diplomatie russe a souligné que la
russie malgré l'état décevant des
relations ce stade voyait l'allemagne
comme un acteur important influent
avocat important avec qui les rapports
ont toujours été particulier je vous
propose d'écouter
nous sommes déçus par l'état actuel des
relations russo allemandes qui traverse
une étape difficile étant donné la ligne
mise en oeuvre par berlin qui vise à une
dissuasion tous azimuts de notre pays
cette politique se manifeste en
particulier par la présence permanente
et significative de la bundeswehr forces
armées de l'allemagne dans le flanc est
de l'otan par sa participation de plus
en plus active aux manoeuvres militaires
que ce bloc mène dans différentes
régions de l'est de l'europe par la mise
à la disposition du territoire de la
république fédérale d'allemagne en tant
que zone de base pour déployer et
approvisionner des troupes américaines
sur le continent européen
le dossier nord stream ii sera
évidemment au cours des pourparlers
achevé en septembre 2021 le gazoduc a
été victime d'une panoplie de sanctions
le régulateur allemand peine encore à
délivrer sa certification en forme que
le 'pipeline' puisse finalement
fonctionner écoutez la mise en service
du north stream 2 contribuera largement
à la sécurité énergétique de tous les
pays de l'union européenne sa
certification par des régulateurs
allemands et par la commission
européenne ne doit pas être reportée ou
politisé de façon artificielle elle la
certification doit être effectué dans le
strict respect des normes existantes que
nous sommes décidés à respecter
en visite à kiev lundi anna lena dr boka
déjà fait une série de déclarations
concernant le nord stream 2 pourrait le
gazoduc doit être complètement conforme
au droit européen ce qui n'est pas
encore le cas et la chef de la
diplomatie allemande a également menacé
de prendre en accord avec ses
partenaires des mesures appropriées à
l'encontre de nord stream ii en cas
d'une escalade russe en ukraine
merci beaucoup on verra c'était virag
hoffman en direct de moscou ce matin